day three of the 2022 nfl draft held
right here in las vegas and tonight we
have team coverage for you john treach
is in studio with more on the raiders
draft picks but first kevin martin live
from the draft experience with more from
those fans on day three hey kevin
well hey sasha three days and a hundred
and thousands of fans later the 2022 nfl
draft is officially in the books as
football fans from across the country
begin to make their way back home but
they will take with them some
unforgettable memories from the red
carpet in the bellagio fountains to the
draft theater and the experience that
was something for everyone and these
fans agree las vegas no doubt set the
bar high for the next cities who are in
line to host this event
i'm happy you know we never experienced
anything like this you know we watched
football on tv but finally we got
football in our city so you know we we
really excited about this you know we
like this it's real good you know i got
some memorabilia you know i'm saying uh
he was out there you know what i'm
saying doing all the fun stuff running
and stuff it was great it was great
so now that the draft is officially in
the books vegas and the nfl can now turn
their attention to the next big event
that will be held right here super bowl
58 in 2024 reporting on the strip kevin
martin live local now
studio excuse me where john treach is
standing by with more on the raiders and
their draft picks right john
thank you kevin thank you so much the
raiders have a tradition of selecting
national champions they've raided the
alabama and claims and rosters the last
three years today's first pick of day
three won a ring running the ball for
georgia the silver and black took
georgia bulldogs amir white in the
fourth round the bulldogs set an nfl
record with 15 draft picks in 20-22 the
raiders took their leading rusher white
shared carries with several guys but
scored 11 touchdowns during the title
run what do i add um just a great guy um
a guy a guy that's gonna come in and
work hard
every single day on
yeah like on every rep inside the film
room in the weight room
he's excited to be here the raiders also
drafted running back britton brown out
of ucla in the seventh round coming up
in sports we'll introduce you to the
rest of the newest raiders